I recently was my birthday in February
and so a group of gals most of my
friends from Canada actually came down
we went to Palm Springs and my best
friend Leslie and I were like what are
we gonna do first of all booze luge
that's the first thing we wanted was
like a giant ice sculpture whose moves
luge right so like a giant ice sculpture
it's like in the shape of a like a
pinball machine and you pour like vodka
in it and then you drink it out the
other side so we were so excited then we
realize we're like we're only here for
three days this is a 750 pound block ice
this thing's not gonna melt by the time
we're ready to go right scratch the
booze luge then we think bouncy castle
that's a natural next step from the
booze luge no it's not at all but then
we couldn't get it in the backyard the
fence was the gate was too small so then
I was like I guess penis cake I guess
that's like the next logical step I
don't see one connection one no one goes
from bouncy castle to penis cake and if
they do they should be arrested well
true very true I haven't been married
before I've never had a bachelorette
party so it's like maybe I should do the
penis cake and then I thought you know
what no I am a beautiful woman in her
prime it's my birthday I'm celebrating
me I want a cake made in the likeness of
my own but I have a great butt you have
a good back I have a great butt its
pristine it's beautiful anyway and so I
said to my boyfriend I was like would
you be comfortable doing a photo shoot
of my butt in a thong for me to send to
a baker so that he can make a cake in
the likeness of my butt and there was
not even a hesitation he just looked me
in the eye and he said absolutely yeah
you had me at will you take a picture
yeah he's like special camera with like
a big lens like I think I was a thrill
no wait a minute so you posed for this
picture correct and and then you sent
this picture of your posterior thank you
a baker correct yeah and the Baker
worked from that and mate was it an
accurate representation it was
stunningly accurate like almost creepy
okay yeah and when I went in he was like
who's butters and I was like mine and he
was like okay I was like that's all I
get okay yeah you can fake it man Wow
really impressive no we you you brought
a picture of the kid yeah let's take a
look at the cake this is
my best friend and I planned this
together we didn't tell any of the other
girls so one night after dinner we went
into the bedroom I stripped down I put
on the same song that I was wearing in
the cake photo and and so I put went
like face down ass up on the bed beside
the cake and so then my Leslie goes and
she's like okay she's ready and and all
the girls filed in and I assumed there'd
be like screaming or squeals or whatever
but literally there was like a hushed
tone and people were like wow that is
beautiful Wow
like it was like they were looking at
diamonds like oh just it's so accurate
they had a real artistic you know
appreciation side by side it's stunning
yeah yeah we've managed to keep that off
the internet though which I think it's
for the best it'll get out there
you